cada cinco años el mismo ritual tiene
lugar en Beijing se ordena los
disidentes que se queden en casa las
fábricas se cierran para reducir la
contaminación y enormes arreglos
florales se alinean en las principales
vías de la capital china todo tiene que
salir perfecto para el Congreso Nacional
del partido comunista este año será la
edición número 20 Pero qué implica
realmente es un evento extremadamente
formal donde cerca de 2.300 delgados en
su mayoría hombres se reúnen en el Gran
Salón del pueblo vienen de todo el país
nominados por organizaciones del partido
para representar a sus 97 millones de
miembros
los procedimientos duran alrededor de
una semana y conducen a la nominación de
nuevas caras en los niveles más altos
del poder en primer lugar la elección a
Puerta cerrada de los 205 miembros del
comité central que reúne las fuerzas
políticas y militares de China este
comité luego designa al polipro que a su
vez nombra el comité permanente el
cuerpo de siete hombres en la parte
superior de la pirámide una de esas
personas termina con el puesto más alto
el que actualmente ocupa chillín Pink el
secretario general del partido comunista
la mayoría de las veces esa misma
persona también es elegida para estar al
frente del ejército más grande del mundo
un paso crucial para consolidar el poder
entonces debemos esperar arduos debates
no todas las decisiones ya han sido
negociadas de antemano por las
diferentes facciones del partido
el objetivo final es Mostrar un amplio
consenso antes de que suene el himno de
la internacional que marca el final del
congreso
[Música]